[inaudible]
chatting earlier.
So,
uh,
I want to start from the beginning of where free solo kind of came to be.
Right.
Um,
I wanted to see,
oh man,
I didn't get my own phone.
So where did the beginning of free solo star tell us kind of the story that
actually set and project into motion the project.
Uh,
well first of all I just wanted to say thank you again for coming out and it
means a lot to see everybody here and so enthusiastic.
Uh,
I didn't necessarily make films because I think about who's going to see them so
much.
But uh,
to see you out here is very heartwarming.
So thank you.
Um,
I did want to ask real quickly,
how many people here have seen free solo?
That's pretty good.
Yeah,
some people place.
That's great.
Awesome.
Well,
uh,
yeah,
so this project or the film,
I guess,
uh,
to give it some context was originally an idea that I came up with about,
you know,
three,
four years ago after a film I made called [inaudible].
And just out of curiosity,
how many people here have seen mirror?
Oh,
that's pretty good too.
Okay.
So I,
uh,
was,
it was really just a character portrait of Alex and really his accomplishments
even before he presold of El cap color already easily worthy of making a film
about.
And Really Alex as a character is always very interesting to me.
Uh,
because you know,
I've been filming and shooting in the mountain world and kind of in the vertical
space and Yosemite for 20 years.
And,
and also outside of that in the ski and snowboard World Base,
you know,
a lot of the different,
uh,
what people call extreme or adventure sports
and
you know,
many of the top athletes at the top of their careers,
uh,
over the last 20 years.
So I've seen a lot of different incredible athletes and Alex is,
was just,
you know,
an anomaly really among like a peer group of anomalies.
And he really,
really stood out in the sense that what he did was
almost like he had a superpower,
you know,
like there are athletic feats that are due to talent and training discipline.
And you know,
people might be predisposed to excel in that particular respective sport.
But what Alex was able to do mentally just seemed
okay,
not from this world,
you know?
And so I really kind of wanted to examine his motivations and take a deep dive
in as a,
as a character.
Yeah.
We didn't talk about making it about El Cap.
Alex came to us with Al Cap and my wife and directing partner Chai,
uh,
was essentially hanging out with Alex because I knew him very well.
I had been traveling and climbing with him for 10 years,
but she didn't know him very well.
So she kind of was just,
you know,
meeting with him to get a sense of his character and if he'd be a good subject
for a future documentary.
And he told her,
he's like,
oh,
that's like I'm interested in making a documentary.
That'd be great.
Uh,
cause I'm thinking about free soloing El cap and my wife,
so casual,
it's not a climber and she,
you know,
she's from Manhattan and she's like,
oh yeah,
that sounds great.
You know,
we really have something
thing to anchor the film.
Okay.
So I uh,
I called her that evening.
I was out on a shoot somewhere and I was like,
how'd your conversations with Alex go?
What do you think?
She's like,
he's a very interesting character.
Uh,
and it's great.
He's going to go free.
So I'll cap.
Yeah.
I almost fell out of my chair because I was like,
he said what?
And he's never spoken to his friends about it,
you know?
And we were,
we didn't even really talk about it amongst ourselves just because it seemed
like
we didn't even want to put it into the ether because we could kind of tell that
everything he was doing was leading.
I mean,
he'd basically free soloed everything else that was,
uh,
of significance except for el Cap.
Yeah.
So it was kind of out there,
you know,
and we didn't even really want to talk about it,
but,
uh,
so then when he presented it to us,
you know,
we,
we actually had to take six months off.
We,
we stepped away from the film because we weren't sure we wanted to make that
film.
Yeah.
Maybe you can talk about that a little bit more during those six months.
I mean,
it's some of that like the moral side of it,
which you can't really film him.
Maybe talk,
talk a little bit about your time.
So you know,
for those of,
you've seen it,
part of the film kind of tries to tackle the ethical issues around the making of
the film because,
and,
and it's really in some ways a dilemma that documentary filmmakers kind of have
to address no matter what.
It's,
if we are supposed to be these objective observers,
uh,
when we bring a camera into a situation,
it necessarily changes,
uh,
what you're observing.
And I think it's called the Hawthorne effect.
You know,
by observing something,
you change the dynamic within what you're observing.
So it,
in this case,
the issue was a little more serious because we were worried that the,
that we could potentially either push him into doing something you wouldn't
normally have done,
as some of us called Kodak courage.
You can like,
oh,
someone's got a camera,
I'm gonna jump off this cliff and the water that's too shallow or whatever.
I mean,
um,
he,
or even worst case scenario while we're filming something would happen in which
we ended up killing him.
And so that obviously took some time to digest and we really had to look at a
few big questions.
Uh,
and I,
I talked to a lot of my mentors in particular,
John Krakauer,
the author is a good friend of mine,
someone I look up to and,
and he has a very good perspective on life.
So I asked John about it and he said,
look,
is he gonna is he going to do this even if you don't film it?
And I said,
yes,
he very likely we'll try to do this even if we're not there.
And he said,
do you think this is an important moment?
Should it be documented if he does do it?
And of course,
as a filming,
here we are.
I said yes.
And it also came down to,
do you feel like you're in the best position to do it safely?
Because if someone else,
you know,
do you feel like that?
Yeah.
If he,
if you feel like you're the best to do it and you're just spending 10 years with
him and really getting to know him and having a really good working relationship
and trust between each other.
You know,
I know his decision making process,
I understand his process in general.
Uh,
when it comes to free solo,
he's very methodical.
He's not,
you know,
people always assume he's a daredevil,
like he is just pulling off a stunt that that to him is totally unacceptable to
him.
It's a craft.
It's like,
it's something that deserves the tension and kind of discipline of,
you know,
craftsmanship like yeah,
fine,
fine craftsmanship and,
and I know that he doesn't climb for the camera,
you know,
and you certainly don't become a climber for the money and the fame,
uh,
you climb because you,
you love it.
And you know,
I know that he doesn't care about being famous at all.
You know what I mean?
He's,
he just,
he just wants to climb and do his thing.
And so having that kind of pure intention there was also,
no,
that's great.
So,
obviously last 30 minutes of the film,
Sam actually climbing,
right?
Going up the route.
Um,
you're following along with him.
And when I first watched it,
probably most people,
you know that he makes it like that's not a surprise.
I'd probably be terrible if you didn't know that going into it right now.
You know,
I,
I've,
I've heard that people,
there are people that have gone into this film not knowing that
and that
horrible,
but,
but so with that,
I think that takes
a very,
um,
a certain touch on the editing and filming process to still be able to build
that tension and excitement of we know the outcome but my hands are still
sweating.
I still feel like I want to throw up,
maybe talk about the accident postproduction it filming side of it,
what went into setting it up to people,
see
what it is.
So I think a couple things,
I mean we went into the film knowing that we want to make a verite film,
which,
you know,
just to bring people into the moment,
the scenes aren't constructed.
A verite film making is really challenging me is you have to really spend so
much time filming and you're,
and you're there constantly to the point where your subject's eventually you
just kind of surrender to the camera and they don't care anymore.
You just kind of disappear.
And that's kind of like the best case scenario.
But you know,
your film with tooth film with someone for two years.
So,
uh,
you're just kind of compiling these moments.
And the reason I'm talking about it because it does come back to your question,
is that
in that kind of filmmaking,
you're really trying to connect people with your subject.
I mean,
films really for me are about creating empathy and it's also about transporting
people into a world that they might not know of.
Um,
in some cases it,
you know,
allows a clarity on misperceptions of,
uh,
of a subject or a topic.
Uh,
so these are all things that we hoped for,
but ultimately,
you know,
your hands aren't going to sweat as much if you don't care about your character.
And so really making the film in a cinema verite film was to get people to,
you know,
really empathize with this character who,
Alex,
uh,
is this,
you know,
he was,
uh,
essentially he was this very shy,
scared kid who was more scared to talk to ask for a climbing that he was to go
free solely.
Yep.
You know,
and,
and that always struck,
you know,
China and I,
uh,
you know about his story.
It's not like he doesn't feel fear and it's not like he's completely on a
motive.
Like inside somewhere in this person is,
you know,
the same beating heart we all have and has the same kind of fears and challenges
that we all face in our lives and act out.
But,
you know,
really getting people to understand that he didn't just come the superhero that
could free Solo el Cap.
Like he worked through all of these fears methodically,
you know,
I mean,
for those that you've seen the film,
there's this part where he's like,
I was scared of different vegetables.
I didn't want to eat them.
But then I made myself systematically eat every vegetable until like I could eat
vegetables.
He says,
I didn't know how to hug people.
I was 23 or 24 and nobody ever hugged me.
And,
but it seemed like people enjoy hugging me
each other.
So I decided
to go out and figure out how to hug people.
And I was there for a lot of that process.
I met him in his early twenties and he used to come up and be like,
and you feel like his fingers in the middle of your back just like tapping you.
And He'd be like,
Alex,
no,
no.
You got to bring it in when you got it
are double hand.
And he's just,
you know,
I think it's,
it's really a beautiful story about this person evolving.
And then he needs Sani of course,
and falls in love while we're in the middle of this production.
So,
yeah,
I mean,
the whole film feels so intimate as you're watching him and Sonya,
she's leaving for that last time.
She's crying in the car.
And when I was thinking about that like,
man,
terrible is that the last time you're ever going to hug him or heavy
conversations when people are talking about someone that they love and maybe not
ever seeing them again.
And,
and those are very real conversations,
uh,
that work captured.
But again,
back to your original question,
you know,
it really was about building this connection with Alice.
Um,
so that when he got there and then of course,
you know,
we built up the climb,
all the kind of sections of the climb that are important in the narrative,
like the free blast and the boulder problem and the for the people has seen the
film.
I mean everybody knows that there's a thumb hole on the boulder problem.
It's very scary.
Um,
but you have to kind of give that a certain treatment as well too.
So as I said,
very intimate experience for the viewers and for the crew.
And also I think
an intimate experience for you and Chai with free soloing.
So maybe prior,
I think you may be a free soloed before,
right?
If free solids and things after filming this project,
how has your views on free,
solo maybe evolved or changed or are they the same?
Yeah,
so I guess really it's about what are my views on risk ultimately?
Uh,
you know,
I have two small children,
two and five,
uh,
very cute
jump up by my gel,
pump it down on my head in the morning and when I haven't had any sleep,
but,
uh,
they really,
it's the film didn't necessarily make me change my evaluation or assessment of
risk for myself or my crew.
I think that happened,
you know,
years ago,
uh,
before I had children because a lot of people say,
does having children change,
you know,
your,
your outlook on risk.
And really,
I think I had my chain,
my outlook on risk change in order for me to have children.
So I feel like I'm pretty conservative even though most people look at what I do
and think it's not conservative.
Uh,
but I also think risk is a relative thing.
So you know what,
it might look very,
very scary to someone.
Um,
to me,
yeah,
if I'm doing something,
it could look very scary to someone,
but for me it feels very in control and,
and uh,
easy.
Hmm.
So,
um,
yeah,
so there's this
scene in the movie,
it's like two minutes long.
We're,
Alex is talking through each pitch kind of shows them training as he's
practicing.
He's like pitch one talking about the free book,
free blast,
slap going all the way up.
So he has it memorized,
right?
He hasn't written down every single move,
every single thumb hole Betty asked to do.
And you also hint at a little bit in the film around the performance that
yourself and the film crew had to put in.
So I'm curious if you can share what did,
what was your version of that?
You know,
were you,
yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well first of all,
Alex,
not only new,
all the moves perfectly on a lot of sections.
He would purposely do them incorrectly so that if he ever did make a mistake,
it would feel at least familiar,
you know?
So that's how detailed he went into it.
Um,
he wore the same clothing the entire time.
We were filming,
uh,
you would think it was because of continuity as a filmmaker,
but it was really because he knew that that's what he was going to wear that
day.
He was going to solo it.
Uh,
and so he never wanted to have to deal with that variable of well waking up in
the morning and the like,
do I want to wear the green shirt or the red shirt
or you know,
on the client,
he'd be very familiar with what he's wearing.
So he,
he really loved her,
like kind of reduce any sort of variables on any sort of level.
Uh,
but in terms of our crew,
you know,
the first criteria on this,
the to be on the high angle team was that you had to be an elite professional
climber.
Uh,
and you know,
just the kind of,
the volume of work that we are going to be doing and high angle terrain meant
that I just couldn't ever have to worry about them making bad decisions up
there.
And so,
uh,
the other criteria,
of course,
they had to be great cinematographers,
meaning there's like three people in the world that get caught.
Um,
all of which I've known and worked with for many years as well.
They're kind of like my crack team,
like go to,
we have like a really heavy high stakes shoot.
I,
I'm sure when they see my fuck my name come up on their phone,
they're like,
oh boy,
because we've done,
we've been all over the place.
But they are in,
in a lot of ways like Alex,
uh,
you know,
in the Ha kind of upper echelon of climbing,
it's all about the details.
It's all about anticipating problems.
It's all about,
you know,
making hard decisions,
um,
when the stakes are high and staying very calm when things are a very tenuous.
So the team,
the makeup of the team is hugely critical.
Uh,
and they also were Alex's friends so that it had these,
there's an emotional layer to it that was also challenging.
Um,
as well as a technical layer.
The technical layer,
obviously being that we had to move very quickly all the time.
Uh,
they were professional climbers,
meaning that not only were they very fast,
but we've all spent time on both sides of the camera.
So we're very sensitive of what it feels like when someone else is filming you,
how that works and what we hate about bad slow camera teams,
you know.
So we were always fast and on time and never had to have him a way.
It always felt very natural for him whenever he was moving.
Uh,
cause we know what it's like to be on the other side.
And essentially he practiced for two years to climb the route and we spent two
years practicing shooting the climbs.
So by the time he went for our choreography,
for how we were going to shoot,
it was
going down to the part where he's talking about the boulder problem.
He says autopilot.
Yeah,
it was probably the same thing for you was the same for us because you know,
you can't let your mind wander into the what ifs.
There's so much to think about.
You've got all your climbing equipment and safety systems and you're changing
lenses on the wall,
you know,
you're pulling focus,
double checking batteries.
He Kinda,
you know,
I mean,
and you're coiling all these ropes,
right?
So when you're filming climbing,
you can't have ropes in your frame,
which means that as he's climbing up and you're moving up,
uh,
you're,
you're hauling ropes.
So if you start filming 1500 feet down the wall and he's,
and you're moving with him as he climbs up that 1500 feet,
well you're carrying 1500 feet of rope by the time you get to the top of that,
which is a lot of weight.
And so,
you know,
everything has to be clipped off carefully.
Cause if like one end of the rope starts to unravel,
the whole thing can shoot down the wall and potentially knock off Alex.
So there's just tons of stuff to think about.
And the director was that he just stay focused on your job.
Don't let your mind wander.
Don't forget to press record.
Yeah,
totally happens.
It totally happens.
And uh,
and that,
so that was kind of the technical side.
But the emotional side was that we had to be totally neutral around Alex.
You know,
cause you couldn't be encouraging or discouraging,
you know,
you were,
we were,
we had an obligation as a film maker to kind of maintain neutral space for him.
Uh,
but still be as Fred.
Yeah.
So there's also a part as he's preparing to actually do the final one where he
succeeds in doing it where you're talking through if something goes wrong,
what do we do when someone says just call nine one one,
tell him what you know,
climber,
did you have discussions as a team or between child yourself or with Alex?
This,
maybe it's pretty morbid,
but I'm sure people are wondering if he had fallen,
what's it?
We're going to scrap the project.
Never released this.
Never tell anybody.
Or is it we tell the story.
Yeah,
no,
I mean we had to address this before we launched into the production.
So these conversations are happening three years ago.
You know,
what happens in the worst case scenario,
uh,
you know,
we didn't necessarily have a clear answer,
but we've addressed it.
And then the issue is that you,
you can't really know what you're going to do in regards to this situation until
you're in it because I think there'll be a lot of inputs that tell you whether
or not it's appropriate or not.
And you know,
it's very sensitive to a lot of different people,
stakeholders like his family and uh,
you know,
Alex would just be like,
oh,
you guys should just make it,
you know,
cause you would've wasted all this
shooting and there wouldn't be,
you might as well make,
you know what I mean?
He's very practical.
I think people are seeing the bill understanding a very practical,
pragmatic and he,
so I think,
you know,
it would have been a very difficult film to make.
Uh,
but we would have probably made it and I certainly wouldn't trust anybody else
with the material.
Um,
but that being said,
we never anticipate if we had anticipated that he was going to fall,
we would certainly never been in the project.
The whole idea was that we trusted that he would either turn around or decide
not to do it before he would ever go up there and you know,
try to force himself to do it and fall off.
You know,
if,
if I ever felt like that was the case,
I would have run away from the project.
Yeah.
So your,
your other projects,
like when you're rude,
the,
the other things that you've worked on,
I feel like the,
the risks are obviously still there,
no oxygen,
very cold,
but it feels potentially less immediate than something like the incident with
free soloing.
And I think the motivation behind a film and the people in Meru climbing that it
seems different than Alex's motivation and,
or is it the same?
Maybe you can go into that.
I mean,
I think there are certainly similarities.
Uh,
yeah,
in the sense that
these are both like free soloing and Alpine climbing in the mountains at
altitude and the cold,
you know,
they're just not what most people kind of imagine being really fun.
Something that you'd really want to pursue and spend your life,
you know,
doing.
But you know,
sometimes you don't get to choose,
you know,
what,
your passion is it,
sometimes it chooses you.
And,
and if you know,
if you're lucky,
then maybe you are a doctor or a lawyer or,
I mean,
I dunno,
Hedge Fund manager,
I don't know.
I'm certainly not a client,
but,
well not certainly I have other opinions about it,
but you know,
it's when you find something that gives you meaning and purpose and it's
something that you,
that moved to,
uh,
and you and,
and there's nothing else that can really feed that like climbing can,
um,
then in that sense they're very similar.
They're just what you love and,
uh,
what you get meaning out of.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
to what degree should we be pursuing that?
I mean,
that's probably up for debate,
but
it is deeply satisfying.
And,
and you know,
we,
we call it a trick.
He used to doors as a useless,
you know,
you're like chasing this thing that probably doesn't do that much for the world,
but it is about the pursuit of perfection and excellence and,
and dreaming like outside of what you think is possible and really pushing
yourself in ways that you might've been afraid of doing before.
Yeah.
So it's a lot about exploration as well.
And there's a,
when Alex first tries and on the free last slap,
he bails out,
um,
after he's talking to Peter Croft and he's like,
no,
I bailed when Peter was like,
it's best thing you could've done.
Um,
but you can tell on Alex's face,
he's so disappointed in himself and he says,
it sucks.
I just needed to end,
you know,
like it's this goal that he feels like he can attain,
but it's still so far away.
I'm still like a year until he actually did it.
Yeah.
And is that something that was tough on your end because that was a very
difficult scene to film because you're so,
you know,
we're also his friends.
Yeah.
The film aside and we care deeply about Alex.
And when you see someone who has a great dream and they've put so much into it,
I mean really,
he's been putting years and years in the back of his mind.
He's been thinking about this.
And to have him really try and fail,
I mean that's,
that's always hard as a friend to see.
Uh,
and so we've,
we felt a lot of compassion for them,
but yet then you had to separate yourself as a filmmaker and,
you know,
film this awful moment,
that he's just kind of really distraught and you could see it in his body
language.
He's all hunched over,
hunched over and disappointed.
Um,
so those,
those moments were always difficult to,
that was a very difficult cause.
None of us wanted to film it.
I was really happy that our Veritate DP was there filming it because we all want
it to hide,
you know?
Um,
but those are the moments where,
you know,
it's an important moment.
You have to capture it.
And,
uh,
and it plays in the film.
You could,
you know,
that's like a classic verite moment where you can feel the moment,
nobody has to explain to you that he's disappointed or anything like that.
You can see it.
And that's like one of those,
you know,
beautiful moments,
I think about Veritas filmmaking.
Yeah.
That was something that when I was watching it,
it felt like seeing like a little kid going up to someone that really looked up
to and it's like,
you know,
I couldn't live up to it.
Yeah.
That was 10.
It was the worst that Peter was there.
The guy that he like looks up to the most,
that just is,
you know,
and him and Peter saying,
you don't ever have to go for it.
You know?
And he's like,
I know Sony.
She's like,
you just don't have to be on like,
he's like,
I know.
I just needed to end the,
you know,
and um,
and I get that too,
because sometimes it makes a lot of sense,
these big objectives.
And then sometimes you step back and you're like,
what am I doing?
You know?
And I think that those are probably existential questions everybody runs into
occasionally.
But,
uh,
he kind of,
he kind of perseveres and pushes through it.
Yeah,
I think that's something maybe everybody's asking you.
I asked you when we were getting lunch,
what's next?
But is there something like that for you?
Maybe not necessarily so like tortured soul,
I just need this to end,
but there is,
is there something for you and chai that you're kind of striving for on a,
on a filmmaking or climbing size or something like that?
I think we just want to make great films,
you know,
and tell great stories and really kind of connect people.
And
I think that's,
I can't,
I already said this,
but you know,
a friend of ours called calls,
films empathy machines,
you know,
you,
you're just trying to create a connection between the subject and um,
the viewer and transport someone and hopefully bring to light it.
Documentaries in particular,
you know,
they can really bring to light,
um,
a lot of different political,
environmental,
social issues that
are important to highlight these days.
And the long format seems to be having a moment right now,
like documentaries this year there've been more kind of bigger box office
documentary releases this year than we've ever seen before.
And I can't tell if it's just a product of the moment.
Um,
kind of our news cycles being so,
you know,
while we fast and,
and people not being able to keep up with it.
And then having this kind of long form journalism in a way making a comeback
because people want to see depth
and,
and you know,
connect with somebody that actually has some,
I mean I know that that's probably typical film in general,
but it feels like an escape from something,
like you said,
the new cycle,
just everything going on now.
It's so crazy.
And to get to see something like Alex resoling this,
it's so far from,
at least to me,
something that seems normal and you get to experience it and just such an
intimate way.
So I think that,
I also think it's,
it's nice to see something,
a little lifting these days and to see someone actually doing something like
there's like a very real physical challenge was a very real mental challenge and
you know,
someone trying to do it and doing it,
it's very,
it's a little bit more tangible than a lot of things that come up.
So I think that's why it's having a moment.
Yeah,
definitely.
So we were also talking at lunch about,
um,
kind of the types of people and the types of climbing that they like.
Um,
and climbing is very quickly growing in popularity,
very popular here.
Look at all these people.
Um,
but how have you personally seen in your own climbing career through making this
film kind of climbing evolve?
And what are your thoughts on that?
Where do you see it going?
I mean,
I started climbing because I loved being outside.
I love the adventure.
I love the movement.
I love the kind of physical,
you know,
problem solving,
mental problem solving of it.
And,
uh,
but the main part being,
wanting to be outside,
but it's funny now,
there's so many climbing gyms and everybody's climbing inside.
Um,
which I actually love doing.
I went and climbed for a few hours this morning.
Uh,
the movement is still amazing,
but I,
I've always tied it to like exploring the world and going on these wild
adventures.
Uh,
but I,
I dunno,
I think climbing,
I love the fact that people are enjoying climbing and then it's becoming more of
a mainstream activity,
I guess.
Uh,
I think it's fun to,
it's a good way to hang out with your friends.
It's a good way to kind of go out and literally be able to interact with an
environment or landscape,
um,
as an activity.
I think it,
it,
at least for me,
it opened my mind to try and to go out and seek these places where I could go
and climb.
So it's been like a great vehicle to do,
uh,
a lot of fun stuff with my friends and my family.
Um,
so I think it's great.
Yeah.
No.
So you,
you talk about climbing outside.
What are some of your other projects?
I know with Alex actually you had that expedition Antarctica coming up,
right?
Do you want to talk a little bit about that?
Alex and I went on an expedition to Antarctica,
you know,
last winter,
last December.
And Alex is still climbing a lot.
You know,
he broke a speed record on the nose this spring.
a lot of people are wondering what he's going to do next.
And uh,
I think he,
there's just a lot of different expressions of climbing.
Climbing isn't just for him free Solo and their sport climbing and bouldering
and all these different types of climbing.
Um,
and you know,
I think we all enjoy all the different aspects of it.
And a part of the other thing about people climbing and getting people to really
enjoy being outside is I find that,
you know,
people are much more in tune and it with the environment and environmental
issues when they love being outside.
And I think that that's a really good thing.
I think that there's potential for more environmental stewardship just because
people learn,
you know,
you want to protect what you love.
And I think when people get out and spend a lot of time and under this blue sky
or under the stars are in the wilderness,
that's a good wilderness therapy for everybody.
We all need,
yeah.
I mean,
last thing,
I guess before we go to that,
what,
what do you have to plug what,
I mean,
obviously free solar boat.
What else is going on with you?
Uh,
no.
Tell us about the whole,
cause I don't know if many people know,
like what actually happens when you release a film.
Oh yeah.
So a bit.
I'm essentially on like the press junket or tour,
uh,
which is like four months long,
you know,
so I haven't been home since the end of August and I've kind of just been,
um,
and,
and it's in support of the film and it's,
uh,
it can feel tedious,
but of course,
you know,
the film's done very well and we couldn't be happier.
Uh,
so just trying to feel grateful and,
and roll along with it.
Um,
obviously I really appreciate people enjoying the film and connecting with the
film.
It's definitely gone far beyond what I ever imagined it would do.
So we're just very grateful for it.
Yep.
Great.
Okay.
Yes.
We'll do some audience questions now and just take it in the front.
Hi,
thanks so much for being here.
Um,
and you know,
climbing is a pretty esoteric sport and it's very rare that it kind of breaks
into the mainstream.
And so I think like taught me to climb up dawn wall or,
or Alex's climber a few of those occasions.
Um,
what do you think the impact of the success of your film is going to have on the
future of climbing?
Like what people do,
how many people get into the sport,
what risks they take?
Yeah,
I think,
I can't tell,
you know,
it's the chicken or the egg thing.
I can't tell if the film is doing well because there's been this huge surge and
the interest in climbing,
but certainly with this film coming up,
it's definitely hit a broader audience than we've ever seen before.
And I feel good about people wanting to climb.
And being interested in climbing for some of the reasons I said.
Uh,
but you know,
it's also about beyond climbing.
I hope people get something out of that story,
you know,
about taking,
um,
you know,
facing their fears and,
and really trying to achieve what they never thought possible before.
And I think that he embodies that.
It's such an incredible way that,
um,
that's more of my kind of hope with it beyond climbing,
I guess.
Great.
We're going to take,
will switch between Doerries so that people weren't able to make it in person.
So when you can see it up top,
but when editing this together,
where they're creative decisions made around portraying this solo as dangerous
as to not oversimplify the act of soloing,
if you worry about the repercussions of newer solo hours upping their game after
seeing this film.
Yeah.
So we really just in some ways,
uh,
are kind of emos always restraint and we certainly didn't have to make this the
free solo seem more
scary than it already was.
Uh,
because you know,
you try to be objective,
you try to,
as a filmmaker,
you try to kind of tell the story.
It is as it is.
You want to give an honest representation of what it is.
Uh,
so we were very restrained on,
on how we covered it.
I mean,
my crew when they saw the film,
we're all like,
that is so restrained.
Like compared to like what being our leader,
the mass because yeah,
I mean it's hard to cover a 3000 foot climb.
Like the number of difficult moves on that wall that aren't in the movie.
I mean that that climb is in some ways notorious and terrifying to think about
even as a professional climber,
even with a rope.
And you know,
I mean when we were filming on that last week before he did it,
there was a team from Germany sponsored by Adidas or Adidas and they were,
they spent five days on the wall and they never climbed every pitch clean,
meaning that they fell multiple times on several of the difficult pitches and
never climbed some of those pitches clean without falling.
And then they spent five days at,
like,
he climbed it in three hours and 56 minutes.
So it's not like,
I mean it's,
it's just beyond.
So in some ways it's very restrained.
Um,
I think we give people the sense of the magnitude and that's what we really
tried to do.
Uh,
in terms of like worrying about repercussions of newer solo hours either the
way,
Alex,
you know,
I have,
I didn't worry about that as much just because free soloing is kind of a self
regulating
activity.
You know,
you can be like,
no,
what?
I want to go free Solo el Cap.
And then you go to the base of El Cap and then you look up at it and you're
like,
whoa.
And then you
climb like 15 feet up off the ground and you're like,
wait,
I can't actually physically move up any further and this is really scary them to
go back down.
So I mean there's like self regulating in a way.
Um,
but you know,
I,
I have thought about a bit more about,
you know,
if people are going to push themselves as free solo lists,
I just hope everybody,
yeah,
I mean I shouldn't say the Darwin awards.
There's certain
you know,
activities that might happen that you just cannot be held for how responsible
for it.
But do you have any plants actually released the full four hours?
Do you have any,
you know,
people have asked that.
We do cause we have,
we certainly have the whole
thanks shot from the long Lens.
Um,
and then pieces all up and mountain rude.
But people have asked this,
you guys ever gonna maybe some day if I see it released on Netflix for hours
climbing horn,
maybe do.
Well maybe I should release that if it happens because of this room [inaudible]
room.
Cool.
All right.
Audience Question.
So my question is about actually Maru and your first attempt.
So you mentioned that there were several times where you used the team near,
near,
near the top of you guys set several lines and proceeded to cross those lines
several times before finally turning back.
How do you go about making those decisions,
setting those lines and deciding which ones you will cross in,
which once you move out across?
Yeah,
that's a good question
because some of it feels,
mmm,
it's hard to articulate like this specific guidelines,
but I mean that's what experience comes from I think.
And you really have to follow your instincts.
A lot of it,
a lot of those instincts also come from,
you know,
knowing that you have to step outside of yourself.
Uh,
certainly the ego plays a role in making sometimes bad decisions.
so you really have to kind of step outside of yourself,
kind of be objective about the actual variables or inputs that you're getting.
I mean,
the thing about it in the mountains am in life,
I guess,
you know,
there are variables you can control and there are variables you can't control.
And a lot of it is identifying which is which.
Uh,
and you know,
our assessment,
that's,
that's always very important.
And that meaning that when you identify the variables that you do control,
that you,
you know,
take great efforts in managing those variables to the best that you can.
Uh,
in terms of crossing those lines,
it's kind of an ongoing assessment of the risks.
And you know,
sometimes you set align and when you get to it and you look around and you are
being objective about the inputs that you're getting,
oftentimes they're telling you to turn around,
but sometimes you get to that line and you're like,
oh,
actually we still have some margin and we'll now set another line as kind of a
marker whether,
yeah,
that's,
I guess it would be,
sometimes it's a physical line or an intellectual line,
but you know,
and then you kind of take the necessary steps to get to that next line and then
you make another evaluation.
Um,
I think it's hard because people sometimes assume that you draw the line,
then you're breaking a,
you're doing something that you don't want to do or shouldn't be doing by
crossing the line.
But it's actually because you've gotten to the line,
made another evaluation and then decided to move forward.
Um,
eventually you get to the edge of that line or you get to the edge,
you get to that next line and you look at it again and you think,
okay,
this is a turnaround moment.
So I remember there's a part in the film where you say,
Alex just constantly pushing the edge and eventually he could find that edge.
Right?
And that's,
and that's something that you deal with a lot and in the world that I live in,
but it's,
it's kind of hard to articulate,
uh,
all the different reasons why.
And when you turn around,
uh,
clearly it's based on,
you know,
the risk reward.
Um,
or if the stakes are too high.
But know those are evaluations that you're making,
you know,
all the time.
Yeah.
All right,
we'll do a,
another dory question about another
high stakes thing.
So at one point in the film,
Alex said he didn't want cameras on him for the boulder problem.
I think he said no one needs to see that.
Obviously that part was filmed.
And it was epic.
Is that something you discussed with Alex prior?
It take some convincing.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
I'm glad people are paying attention.
No,
very,
it seems like everybody that works here pays very good.
Okay.
It is.
Uh,
but yes,
he does say that he doesn't want anybody to film it at one point.
Uh,
then he goes up,
he fails on that one attempt and his realization and learning from it is that,
okay,
if I'm going to climb in front of my friends,
it just means I have to be way better prepared in the film.
It's kind of portray that,
you know,
he turns around because of too many people around and the cameras and stuff,
but he actually just wasn't really ready.
Uh,
his ankle was still swollen and it was really cold that he couldn't feel his
toes.
Um,
but he did realize,
look,
I just have to be better prepared,
which we all thought it was great.
Uh,
so as he got closer and closer in his training to the day that he actually went
for it,
you know,
it was a very ongoing,
open conversation.
The thing is,
is I was never pushing for it because I didn't need to push Alex and say,
we really want a camera that we were like,
he knows exactly what I,
you know,
what this is all about.
And that of course,
you know,
if possible we'd have a camera there,
but if not,
that's fine.
That's the whole that thing where,
you know,
you could never let the needs of the film,
outweigh the needs of Alex and his experience,
which is how we went into the film.
We were very clear with him and with the crew and with our executive producers
and with the studio that this,
you know,
the film,
so you understand the needs of the film will never outweigh his safety and his
experience.
So,
um,
eventually you had that conversation and he was like,
yeah,
I'm,
he's like,
definitely,
that's fine.
That's not going to bother me.
Uh,
but I don't want a person there.
So we put remote cameras there and,
and uh,
it was fine.
And,
and the reason being that clearly he didn't,
you know,
if he felt that he didn't want his friends to see it,
but
he knew that
she wouldn't be stressed,
but we would be projecting fear onto him,
which would then change how he was feeling in the client.
And so that's why we had a fixed cameras.
Yeah.
Throughout the film,
generally when you were shown,
um,
you were kind of always stressed,
just
you were at least for his final attempt where he succeeds,
you were at the top,
you weren't really filming where you kind of just driving?
I was actually,
uh,
it does look like I was at the top because I was actually filming the Enduro
Corner,
but I,
so I was also shooting in National Geographic assignment for the magazine.
During the two years we were producing and directing this.
So I had a still camera bolted to the top of my film camera.
And so I've,
after I found him on the enduro corner,
I was shooting stills simultaneously.
Then he goes up and he traverses that,
uh,
we didn't have enough cameraman to shoot.
Uh,
I had one on the top,
basically my Veritate DP when shot,
I'm going to the base and then ran all the way around and up to the top.
Um,
yeah,
it's a long,
wait,
that's the basic expectation now that you have to be able to move like that.
But I didn't have a still photographer up there obviously for you're shooting in
a two year assignment of Alex free solely or cap,
you kind of have to get topping out.
So I,
I was,
as soon as he crossed above me and over on the traverse,
I had to put all the camera on equipment and the way and jog up to the top,
but it's like
close to a thousand feet or 800 feet.
And so I'm just going as fast as they can and he's around the corner.
I can't see him.
But the whole ground crew was watching in the long lens and they said we were
like going.
Right,
exactly.
They're like,
oh Jimmy,
go.
Then the lines intersected at one point.
So right when I,
to this one anchor,
I looked down and Alex is like scampering up the rock and I was just like,
Alex,
I was like,
you just give me six weeks.
Second,
he pulled out his phone,
you live in his lane and he just said,
I'm about to break four hours.
And we didn't say another word.
I knew what that meant.
I was like,
Alex does not want four hours in one minute.
Okay.
So I just turned around and I juggle
to the top and that's why I'm like sweating profusely while is that too?
Um,
constant hair falling out.
So I had to get to the top
and shoot the photos of him tapping out.
I beat him by like,
uh,
like a minute or something.
Good word.
Yeah.
All right.
So probably have time for one more in person question.
Hi there.
Thanks for coming.
Um,
my questions are two part.
One is how has your relationship with Alex change since the,
you know,
the filming process and ending this with him and maybe more philosophically,
how do you think Alex has relationship with climbing has changed after he's
finished?
Um,
this climb.
Uh,
well my religion with Alex is about the same.
Like we ha he likes to throw me under the bus every so often and I like to throw
him under the bus.
That resa no,
but we've always had like a very good relationship and I think Alex,
actually I think we are closer.
I mean through the process certainly has brought us closer.
Uh,
I also think that he is really appreciative of what the film is cause he didn't
ever really care about the film he carried about free soloing El Cap.
He knew that we were doing our thing.
Um,
but I think he's been surprised that,
you know,
how well it's been received and that people really feel inspired by him,
are connected to him.
Uh,
and
okay.
You know,
I,
I think he enjoys that.
Uh,
he,
he loves going to watch the end of the film because,
you know,
it's like,
he's like,
oh,
I get to relive the best moment of my life on this huge screen with all these
people all the time.
Uh,
but his relationship to climbing though,
and free soloing,
I mean he is still,
you know,
going to climb as much as he possibly can cause he loves climbing.
Uh,
is he going to be pushing for huge free solos?
I,
you know,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I think he's just like most climbers.
Like you're,
you have to be kind of motivated,
inspired to climb something to really go after it.
But I think that he has in soloing oh,
cap.
I mean,
there isn't like a hole.
There isn't a whole lot elsewhere.
You can go with it.
Um,
he's,
he's free soloing El Cap,
so I think he'll probably
focus his energy and all the different expressions of climbing that are out
there and enjoy it as moment.
And then he's really,
his whole thing too is like,
he's like,
fame is useless unless you can use it for good.
That's,
so he's pivoting a lot of the attention towards his Honnold foundation,
uh,
you know,
which does solar projects around the world and,
and that is something that he,
you know,
really believes in.
So,
yeah.
That's great.
So I think that it's probably all the time we have for questions.
I mean,
but the remaining few minutes that we have,
anything you want to plug pitch?
No,
not really.
I mean,
I just hope you all enjoy the film and I really appreciate,
again,
that you follow the work and that you're going to see it and that you came out
to see me today,
I guess.
Let me,
that's awesome.
So thank you so much.
[inaudible].